folks chris waters here on the game spot
stage at e3 it's samurai warriors four
time joining me on the couch we've got
koi numasan and peter from tecmo coy and
uh gentlemen please uh make yourselves
comfortable thank you for coming
thank you we've got a playstation 4 on
the table here we're going to be playing
the game i think we should just start to
hop right in and uh you know also give
people an idea samurai warriors for it's
been a few years since we had a full-on
samurai warriors game
on
yeah it actually has been about four
years since the last one so yeah it's
we're happy to bring it back
excellent people are waiting
for so it's actually the 10th
anniversary for samurai warriors so you
know in order to celebrate that we've
come out with the next number title in
the series pretty big landmark 10 years
now the
samurai warriors between
samurai warriors dynasty warriors
there's there's been a lot of historical
ground covered uh where where's the
setting for samurai warriors sort of
what what what are you guys capturing
here
warriors takes place in the warring
states period japanese history and
that's around like 15 80
1580s to the early 1600s um it's a time
of like a lot of internal strife within
the come within the country um
and that's where this is taking place
and you know one of the
one of the things that people i think
really enjoy about these games is just
the breadth of characters that
you get to play and uh the roster has
has grown i imagine this year uh yet
again uh how many what's the you know
how many different characters what is
when you are building a roster
what bases do you want to cover what are
you trying to present in terms of player
options
enjoy
so
in the past the past title had around 43
characters we think this has over 50
characters this time
tonight
who's going to show up um the warring
stage period you have a lot of warriors
uh within japan there are a lot of
people
that uh japanese people know
and they were like oh i'd love to play
as that guy and so there's a rich you
know
you know history of like real characters
that we can pick from yeah and then you
know we think about the story
and figure out you know what kind of
story would we want to tell for
uh for this installment and once that
gets that we figure okay well this
person will work this person will work
and that's how we pick and choose
very cool uh so
speaking of characters actually i think
there are two character portraits on
screen right now and that's
something new for samurai warriors for
you're able to to play as two different
characters well it's a hot swap between
them
is a partner
so yeah you can actually swap between
them with the option button you'll
switch between the characters and you
know you'll have to use both characters
well to uh control the battlefield and
they can be at different points in the
battlefield exactly yeah yeah they're
not together they're doing their own
thing and you can swap between them now
of course sort of managing the
battlefield and going to you know you're
not just out here to defeat every
soldier you see there's a lot we've been
seeing objectives pop up there's uh sort
of strategic considerations that pop up
in the middle of battle
in terms of the scope of these conflicts
is developing for having it come to the
playstation 4 is that giving you guys
any uh a little more oomph in terms of
what you can do
i know
so yeah this absolutely has the most
characters on screen of any of the games
that we've done in the past
um we've also gone back and really uh up
the particle effects the lighting um and
really tune that to take advantage of
the ps4 so this is definitely like the
best looking one in the series
and it's not just on the ps4
in fact it's out is uh ps3 and ps vita
as well
hi hey
so yeah there are uh ps3 and vs vita
versions as well um so if you don't have
a ps4 definitely check it out on the
other platforms um but the ps4 is
definitely like the best of the button
the nicest of the bunch yeah what helps
um once you get into sort of developing
and publishing games on multiple
playstation systems you know they've
been so good about cultivating this
ecosystem of cross saves and cross buy
and uh you know remote play uh
or any of these features things that
samurai warriors 4 takes advantage of
that
oh
so yeah um we we do use cross saves um
as well as downloadable content if you
buy downloadable content for one
platform you can use it across all three
excellent
uh now if i'm not mistaken samurai
warriors 4 has already been released in
japan earlier this year uh how has the
public reception been to for the return
of samurai warriors
foreign
so the ps4 version is actually not out
in japan so the ps4 version we're really
focusing on the western market trying to
make sure we nail it for that
vita versions those are out in japan um
and you know being the 10th anniversary
we put a lot of effort into that and you
know we're really thankful that it to
all the fans who went out and bought it
we've received a lot of good feedback
systems
so it's the the new switching feature
the character swapping feature fans
really like that out there um so
definitely check it out
yeah i think you know anything that lets
you
be even more powerful on the bad
battlefield control a little bit more of
the action certainly seems right in the
vein of what samurai warriors fans
really enjoy
or not
yeah you know the the tactical aspect of
the warrior series is something that we
really you know is very important to the
series uh for gameplay so we're really
happy to like to hear that kind of
feedback yes that's exactly you know
what we're going for uh let's talk a
little bit about any multiplayer options
you guys have here
yeah we do have multiplayer
so um during story mode is actually
split screen story mode so multiple
players can play through the story
together
excellent
uh and do those players if you're do you
still get to switch between the two
players when you're playing two players
against
so
we
we created the character swapping with
the image of it being sort of first and
second player okay so when you're in
multiplayer like you're switching to the
second player
sure
i kind of figured that yeah it seems
natural all right uh
that was a pretty flashy job right there
uh like a little sort of overpowered
attack one of those guys
um
so this is sort of the
it's a
one rank up from a musso attack so more
powerful attack yes
very cool uh
so
before we conclude the demo here is
there anything else about samurai
warriors 4 you'd like to to point out to
the fans out there
thank god
i know
so you know samurai warriors is really
you know it's made uh in japan and
dealing with japanese history and all of
that um so we're we're actually really
happy when fans out here you know send
us emails and say hey are you bringing
this out west um
so that's just it's a really good
feeling for being you know the the 10th
anniversary first numbered samurai
warriors in four years
and it's coming out you know for the
west really tuned for the west on the
ps4 we really hope that people you know
get their hands on it try it out play it
and have a lot of fun with it so what
are the dates
so in
japan there's a there's an anime box and
the uh it comes the game comes with like
a one-hour anime that they've made no
kidding so if you like anime definitely
check that out
all right and when can folks get their
hands on
thank you guys for so much for coming on
and showing off samurai warriors four
you got to go
mess up